a teper 2014 in Berlin some of the best
new tech has been on display here's on
the biggest threats to Apple's new
products Chinese company while way
presented the ascend mate 7 smartphone
with a six-inch displayed on a several
companies reaping the rewards from
phones with large screens while way says
it will double its share of the global
market in just five years Japanese firms
Sony showed off mobile devices that can
play playstation games and a waterproof
these might not trouble apple dough has
xperia smartphones barely break into the
top 10 in global shipments but it was
apples biggest competitor samsung who
look best position there was the new
note and the note edge the technology on
this phablet was a real show stealer in
berlin but one of the biggest rumours of
our apple circulating is whether it will
launch a SmartWatch type device Samsung
built on previous launches with its new
gear it's big in just a year but the
South Korean firm wasn't the only one
launching a timepiece LG and Motorola
launched round-faced watches hoping to
take a lead on the fashion front etho
also saw the likes of aces though their
hat in the ring with a device Nell sell
for less than two hundred dollars
anything apple launches will have to do
more than just catch the eye